House of the Dragon is a Game of Thrones prequel
show that is confirmed by HBO’s president
to air in 2022.
Miguel Sapochnik and Ryan Condal will serve
as showrunners and executive producers. George
R. R. Martin will also serve as executive
producer.
It is based on George RR Martin’s Targaryen
history book Fire And Blood volume 1 and on
Martin’s yet unfinished Fire And Blood volume
2 book.
“Fire & Blood begins their tale with the
legendary Aegon the Conqueror, creator of
the Iron Throne, and goes on to recount the
generations of Targaryens who fought to hold
that iconic seat, all the way up to the civil
war that nearly tore their dynasty apart.”
That's Fire And Blood volume 1.
The yet unreleased Fire And Blood volume 2
will continue from where part 1 ended, with
Rhaenyra Targaryen's son Aegon lll's reign
and will cover Blackyre rebellions, war with
Dorne and go all the way to the Mad King and
Robert's Rebellion that ended Targaryen dynasty.
Key event of the prequel will be the Dance
of the Dragon, a Targaryen civil war.
The Dance of the Dragons was the most devastating
war in the history of the Seven Kingdoms.
A war of succession between Aegon II and his
half-sister Rhaenyra over their father Viserys
I's throne.
Targaryens fought Targaryens, bothers fought
brothers, dragons fought dragons.
One of the supporters of Rhaenyra was Nettles.
Nettles was a dragon-rider for Rhaenyra Targaryen's
faction during the Dance of the Dragons.
She was either a lover or bastard daughter
of Daemon Targaryen, or maybe even both.
Nettles, also known as Netty, was a dragonseed
and the first and possibly the last dragonrider
of the dragon Sheepstealer. Netty was a small
brown-skinned girl with black hair and brown
eyes.
This would make Nettles the only non-white
dragon-rider in the history of Westeros (although
not the only female dragon-rider: several
women in Rhaenyra's faction including Rhaenyra
herself were dragon-riders). The skinny girl
had crooked teeth and scarred nose. According
to Gyldayn, she could not be called pretty.
Nettles was foul-mouthed, filthy, and fearless.
Nettles was a bastard of House Targaryen - known
as one of the "dragonseeds".
Her exact parentage is unknown, but she did
not resemble her Targaryen ancestors - instead
she was notably dark-skinned (like a Summer
Islander). According to Mushroom, Nettles
was a bastard of uncertain birth. She grew
up homeless in Spicetown and Hull on the island
of Driftmark.
According to Septon Eustace, the girl's nose
was slit after she was caught thieving.
Her cunning and intelligence was best evidenced
in how she managed to claim her dragon.
As the great Targaryen civil war known as
the Dance of the Dragons progressed, Rhaenyra
Targaryen's faction - which was based on Dragonstone
- realized that they had more living dragons
than dragon-riders, with six riderless beasts
nesting on the island.
It’s believed that only those of Targaryen
blood can successfully bond with and ride
a dragon, so they proclaimed rewards for any
commoners on Dragonstone who could successfully
bond with one of the unclaimed dragons specifically
Targaryen bastards and descendants of Targaryen
bastards who had been fathered over the years
on commoners of the island by young Targaryen
princes. When it was decided by Prince Jacaerys
Velaryon that the blacks needed more dragonriders
during the Dance of the Dragons, several "dragonseeds"
on Dragonstone came forward to answer the
prince's call in 129 AC. Many died or were
injured by dragons, but then the sixteen years
of age, Nettles was able to tame the wild
dragon Sheepstealer. Three of the dragons
had known riders before so they were claimed
before too long, but the other three were
"wild" dragons - they had grown to adulthood
never being successfully claimed by any rider
at all, and thus were unused to the presence
of humans. Eventually many thought it was
impossible to bond with a wild dragon at all
- until Nettles became the only one to succeed,
when she bonded with the dragon known as "Sheepstealer"
(a basic descriptive name the commoners of
the island referred to him by, given that
he had a taste for sheep from their flocks).
Nettles realized that simply walking right
up to a wild dragon and attempting to mount
it was foolhardy (and had gotten many of the
other dragonseeds killed), so she cleverly
left a freshly killed sheep every day for
an extended period of time, allowing Sheepstealer
to become gradually used to her presence.
Nettles rode her dragon throughout the rest
of the war. Her dragon Sheepstealer was actually
one of the older and larger ones in the Dance,
hatched "when the Old King was young" (Jaehaerys
I) meaning he was at least 80 years old and
probably bigger than either Rhaenyra's dragon
Syrax or Daemon's dragon Caraxes. He was described
as being an ugly mud-brown color for this
reason, not unlike Nettles herself, previous
Targaryens had ignored Sheepstealer, preferring
dragons with what they felt were more beautiful
colors. Nettles participated in the massive
Battle of the Gullet, one of the largest naval
battles in history. Nettles fought valiantly
on behalf of Queen Rhaenyra Targaryen in the
Battle of the Gullet. While her fellow dragonriders
Hugh the Hammer and Ulf the White celebrated
after the battle, Nettles was upset by the
death of Jacaerys. During the fall of King's
Landing, Nettles landed Sheepstealer on Visenya's
Hill. After the capture of King's Landing,
she accompanied Rhaenyra's husband (and uncle)
Daemon Targaryen with his dragon Caraxes,
as they hunted through the Riverlands for
Prince Aemond Targaryen on the great dragon
Vhagar, who was burning out the entire region
in a one-man, one-dragon private war. Despite
having the largest and greatest living dragon
alive, however, Aemond was at least wise enough
not to risk riding Vhagar into a two-against-one
fight, so he simply withdrew whenever they
neared and moved on to burn out some other
part of the Riverlands. While searching the
riverlands for Prince Aemond Targaryen and
Vhagar, Prince Daemon Targaryen, Rhaenyra's
husband, was constantly accompanied by Nettles,
both in the sky and at their base, Maidenpool.
According to Mushroom, Daemon had come to
love the girl and took her as his bedmate.
In contrast, Norren, the maester at Maidenpool,
stated the dragonriders had separate bedrooms
and that Daemon doted upon Nettles "as a man
might dote upon his daughter". Norren described
Daemon teaching Nettles common courtesies
and giving her fine gifts such as an ivory
hairbrush, a silvered looking glass, a velvet
and satin cloak, and leather riding boots.
Maidservants said Daemon showed Nettles how
to wash, sharing a single tub at times. Given
that Daemon was old enough to be Nettles's
father, it’s not impossible that she actually
was his bastard daughter, and this is the
reason they seemed to have unusually close
bond. Queen Rhaenyra's court at the Red Keep
was outraged by the treasons of Tumbleton
done by Ulf and Hugh. Lady Mysaria, long Daemon's
paramour, fed the growing distrust of Rhaenyra
against the dragonseeds with rumors about
Nettles and Daemon's relationship. Rhaenyra
now mistrusted all the dragonseeds, including
the girl who rode with her husband Daemon,
hunting Aemond in the Riverlands. She ordered
the girl's head to be sent to her. But there
was a complication; as well as her dragon,
the girl had taken to riding Daemon, according
to some, while according to others, Daemon
simply took care of her as if she was his
own child. Rhaenyra raged, declaring that
Nettles used spells to bond with Sheepstealer
and to seduce the prince. The queen sent a
raven to Manfryd Mooton, Lord of Maidenpool,
requesting the girl's head and ordering Daemon
to return to the capital. Manfryd and his
advisors disobeyed, however. When Maester
Norren informed Daemon that Rhaenyra had declared
Nettles a traitor, Daemon was disgusted and
allowed her to escape. After killing a large
black ram and feeding it to her dragon, a
tearful Nettles flew Sheepstealer into the
morning mists of the Bay of Crabs.
The disappearance of Nettles enraged Rhaenyra.
Instead of returning to his wife, Daemon flew
to Harrenhal, where he issued a challenge
to Aemond to come and face him alone. Both
Aemond and Daemon later arrived at Harrenhal
with their dragons and in the subsequent Battle
Above the Gods Eye where both men and both
dragons perished. Since Daemon's body was
never found in the Gods Eye while Aemond's
was as well as their dragons, some songs claim
that he survived the encounter and found his
way back to Nettles. There are multiple theories
about Nettles' fate that people in the world
of Westeros believe. Some believe that she
rode out so far over the sea that Sheepstealer
was too tired to fly back to land, and both
dragon and rider drowned. Nettles and Sheepstealer
were never seen again.
Rumors abound, however, that this was just
a ruse to hide from Rhaenyra, and in truth
Nettles later doubled back to land, and that
Daemon miraculously survived his fall into
the Gods Eye lake, and the two lived out their
days together on the hidden Isle of Faces
- this tale is popular among the romantic
singers. Some maesters believe that the Burned
Men originated from members of the Painted
Dogs who worshipped a fire-witch who would
be Nettles and her dragon who would be Sheepstealer
in a hidden vale after the Dance, bringing
gifts to the dragon woman and displaying burns
as proof of their valor. Nettles reportedly
spent her days in the Vale. When King Aegon
II Targaryen regained the Iron Throne after
Rhaenyra's death, there were reports that
Sheepstealer had been seen at Crackclaw Point
and the Mountains of the Moon. In 134 AC during
the reign of King Aegon III Targaryen, Ser
Robert Rowan led a royal army to the Vale
of Arryn to support Ser Joffrey Arryn. Robert's
men encountered Sheepstealer and ragged Nettles
in a cave and in the ensuing fight sixteen
men were slain and threescore more were wounded.
Nettles and her dragon were last seen flying
deeper into the Mountains of the Moon. There
is no doubt that Fire And Blood volume 2 will
offer certain answers to these questions when
the book is finally released. Who knows maybe
we even read about legendary Daemon Targaryen
again who might be alive and well with Nettles.
Whatever the case, Nettles, as a Targaryen
bastard and a dragonrider plays an important
role in the House of the Dragon and it will
be interesting to see how all the mysteries
surrounding her will be portrayed, from her
heritage to her relationship with Daemon,
to whatever happens with her later. Again,
House of the Dragon, Game of Thrones prequel
based on House Targaryen's most exciting parts
of history is coming in 2022 on HBO. Let me
know your thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below.
Thank you so much for watching, hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did make sure to give
it a big thumbs upand I hope to see you in
the next one, peace!